[Music]
in the aftermath of the slap that rocked
the oscars could will smith actually
lose his best actor award does the
academy have a process for that keep
watching for the answers the 94th
academy awards won't be remembered as
the year kota won best picture or dune
nearly swept the technical awards the
entire ceremony has been overshadowed by
will smith's response to a chris rock
joke about jada pink and smith's
alopecia when the comedian took the
stage to present the award for best
documentary feature while smith appeared
to initially laugh at rock's joke a
throwaway quip comparing piket smith's
short hairstyle to demi moore's
character in the 1997 film gi jane the
knight's eventual best actor winner then
stood up approached rock on stage and
slapped him in the face it was censored
in the us broadcast but videos of the
international feed of the show proved
that rock noted will smith just slap the
[ __ ] out of me to which smith replied
twice keep my wife's name out of your
mouth a bewildered dolby theater
audience realized they weren't watching
some bizarre sketch smith did in fact
genuinely slap rock who proceeded to
plead his case that it was just a joke
about g.i jane before awkwardly
transitioning back to handing out the
best documentary feature award which
went to summer of soul the unprecedented
altercation loomed large over the rest
of the ceremony smith took the stage a
second time later that night to accept
the award for best actor in his surreal
tear-filled speech smith compared his
action to those of richard williams who
he portrays in the film for which he won
king richard this prompted questions
about whether he should even be allowed
to keep the award you're looking at this
going okay academy so what are you going
to do about it what are you gonna do
about this because clearly there were no
consequences that night the new york
post sarah nathan reported that industry
insiders are suggesting that smith may
be asked to give his oscar back people
magazine reported that behind the scenes
abc and academy representatives
scrambled to understand what happened
and that removing smith from the show
was seriously discussed however
uncomfortable the altercation was
members of the academy present at the
dolby theater appeared to attempt to
ease tension as social media erupted in
response cameras showed both will smith
and jada pinkett smith laughing from
their seats as sean p diddy combs told
the audience that smith and rock would
solve that like family at an after party
after the ceremony ended the academy
tweeted the academy does not condone
violence of any form the post noted that
the organization took great pains to
create standards of conduct for academy
members in 2017. according to variety
this code states in addition to
achieving excellence in the field of
motion picture arts and sciences members
must also behave ethically by upholding
the academy's values of respect for
human dignity inclusion and a supportive
environment that fosters creativity
there is no place in the academy for
people who abuse their status power or
influence in a manner that violates
recognized standards of decency but even
with the code of conduct there does not
appear to be a formal process for
stripping academy members of an award
luckily it does appear the conflict was
largely resolved in the aftermath of the
shocking oscars moment according to nbc
news los angeles police said in a
statement that rock declined to press
charges page six likewise reported that
combs confirmed rock and smith made
amends after the ceremony variety
reported that smith answered a question
about how he was doing with it's all
love the day after the ceremony march 28
2022 smith issued a direct apology to
rock on instagram he wrote in part i
would like to publicly apologize to you
chris i was out of line and i was wrong
i'm embarrassed and my actions were not
indicative of the man i want to be the
smith family has been in the news
frequently throughout this awards season
jada pinkett smith posted on instagram
in december 2021 that she shaved her
head due to hair loss from her alopecia
and will smith spoke candidly about
their at times non-monogamous marriage
and a november 2021 gq feature the road
don't look like everybody thinks it's
supposed to look but you know don't try
this at home children
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]